so this talk is about agile software
architecture and really just about I
guess what is software architecture what
the architects do what is agile how are
those two ideas mesh together so I'm
quite grateful that you all decided to
come on Friday afternoon to the last
talk here about that kind of topic
rather than going watching someone show
you funny cat pictures so thanks very
much I appreciate that and what I want
to do this talk a little bit it's kind
of addressed this challenge that I think
has emerged for architecture with this
idea of people saying essentially we
don't need architects anymore that idea
is dead we're all self you know
organizing collaborative teams now able
to spontaneously create great software
and we don't need any kind of
architectural direction that's who I am
it just says that I'm old really in
summary the only point I try and pull
out ever is it's one of the bottom by
the way in the UK English guys is
gender-neutral but I probably should
change this I was gonna change this
slide but I discovered these slight
problem that so I changed George about
two and a half weeks ago got a new Mac
it didn't have it comes with Google's
productivity software so I downloaded
PowerPoint and only the officer Mac
quite happily and it said to me in your
Microsoft account is registered in the
UK you are in Portugal in you can't
activate your software so I can't
actually edit my slide deck that's fine
but I couldn't I couldn't tweet there
for you but the point I want to raise is
that you know it's because I'm standing
here it doesn't mean that I am tequila
smart my one positive characteristic
probably is that I am I will just grind
my way Steve through stuff eventually
but I'm putting this Martin any of you
and you know really you could be here
and it's a difficult as you take the
first steps of giving a lightning talk
or to use the group doing a few user
group talks submitting to conferences
and really it's worth it as a journey
and I'll encourage everyone
to have a stab it at some point that's
where I used to work but I can't edit
the slides so that's an open source
projects I work on brighter who's a
developer in the room okay it's a Python
developer in Europe so we run we write a
framework which kind of equates with
things that mass transit and service bus
we essentially provide a a kind of
mediator like handler and dispatcher to
those handlers of commands and events
but we let you do it out of process
across effectively a message oriented
middleware and we handle all the kind of
reliability concerns are generally doing
that and we support all of the keep and
things like out boxing in box etc so you
wants me to do the heavy lifting for you
on that kind of approach we are an
option okay what I want to talk about
today I want to just dig into a few of
the myths that I see out there and try
and kind of say here's some things that
I think are quite broadly believed about
software architects and software
architecture that I do not think are
true and their statements been made by
some quite famous people so I didn't
know worth challenging and then I will
go into what I think software
architecture is what I like what I think
it actually is but what a number of more
learning people and I think is about
what agile is and then talk about this
convergence of the two and was when we
get into the myths we'll talk a little
bit about why that has been
traditionally seen as problematic in
some ways and then towards the end we
talked about earlier who is the software
architect on your team we probably won't
have time for Q&A because there are I
think 63 slides and this talk only lasts
an hour so the math is not in my favor
of reaching the QA department but you
never know things happen I tend to go
off piste a lot against my own slide
deck so you might finish in a half an
hour who knows everyone knows here
Martin Fowler is yeah so Martin Fowler
you know famous guy wrote refactoring he
wrote the patterns of enterprise
application development and a lot of my
early career I learned an enormous
amount from the kind of stuff that
Martin captured a lot would seem to come
from your work people like Kent back on
early axp projects and something
developing that thought works
he wrote a famous paper called who needs
a software architect and if you read
that paper you can get the impression
quite strongly that mine doesn't really
like software architects very much
Martin's is essentially that software
architecture architects just a title we
give somebody after a number of years of
loyal service because we've made them
like you know the senior engineer and
then the team lead and then the
principal engineer and we need to give
him a new title so we can pay him more
money so they won't leave the company
so eventually start calling the
architect and that's kind of Martin's
theory that's what software architects
are they just basically very expensive
software developers who needed a fancy
title in order to stay in the
organization and yeah his wife is also a
architect which becomes actual building
architecture becomes important later and
so he takes this quote which we see
basically from a number of people I
think it originally comes to Grady Booch
will sit again later saying architecture
is the decisions you wish you could get
right early in the project and so says
what actually then this architecture
thing is just things that people
perceive as being hard to change
so he says the architecture of the
system of the things that people
perceive to be hard to change a man says
well you know what really people should
do in this kind of position is actually
just solve these problems once and for
all in fact they're making the sauce
redundant and one of the examples he
uses his database migration says once
upon a time when we wanted to change
this that the shape of our objects and
change the schema or whatever database
they persisted to that was quite a hard
operation and we used to think about it
quite a lot and write all these complex
scripts by hand and then cut along
anything without rails with migrations
and we just press the buttons and I've
actually generated scripts that effect
the migration force and once that's
ideal architectural thinking right
eliminating the need to do any kind of
upfront thinking about things just speed
developers along right remove remove all
the impediments to change and eventually
won't need architects at all because all
the things that are hard to change which
is what architecture is therefore will
have been removed everything will be
easy to change I'm working architects
anymore martin also said they should
never hire anyone at ThoughtWorks who
had the word architect as a job title
ever in their entire lives
say he's he's a little bit extreme if
you ask me on this position
okay and and he said oh you know my
wife's a building architect and building
architects don't do anything to do
really with the construction process
they just smooth important wealthy
clients and say this is how we're going
to live in our wonderful building and
that is true by the way there's a you
ever had a Norman Foster Dona Fausta
British architect longer Foster's famous
because he comes up with these really
fantastic schemes for his customers most
of them are always completely
unbuildable and there's one firm that
specializes in building Norman Foster's
or designs because they're so hard so
yeah
and she says basically both
architectures really this this person
that you know much more like in Sumter
cases that are up appointed you may be
the product manager right so he says
we've misused the term from his point of
view the person who really understands
what the stakeholder wants and defines
how we're going to work with it and how
the customer will use it that's a
product manager so the closest thing to
a building architect from martin's point
of view is a product manager so he
doesn't really like this idea we've
created evolved text at all so Grady
Booch famous basically you guys know
Grady Booch is except behind rip red
very early on one of the people that
wrote kind of the classic books on
object-oriented programming I think is
one of the guys behind the early
versions of UML for example what became
UML and he said basically the
architecture of this
is the significant design decisions this
is kinda where Martin got the quote from
I think right well we measure
significance by cost of change and
impact and you will you will hear this
idea a lot right this idea that says
architecture is all these hard to change
things it's all these things that where
if I don't make the decision right at
the front of the at the beginning of the
process it will be very difficult for me
to reverse that decision make a later
one a classic one that's always ready to
the problem of undo the idea if I don't
build in undo early enough then it's
difficult to actually then write it in
later so I have to make some decisions
up front which enable me to say it's
gonna be importantly to support undo so
I'm going to build it in early because
in a year's time it's gonna be really
hard to put that into this into the
software and I think the reason that we
ended up with this kind of definition
which says architectures are things that
are hard to change is because of the
evolution from waterfall star delivery
methods into agile methods so Martin is
talk that works for a company that sells
you you know agile transformation and
I'm with favor a job but they had kind
of an issue in a sense that in the
waterfall model we had these clear
phases right we have kind of our design
phase or implementation phase and our QA
phase and architecture was clearly a
theme that happened in the design phase
where somebody in the room spat out UML
diagrams presented them to the team as
some of a tablet of stone and said here
I've I've designed the system all you
need to do now just write some pesky
lines of code and everything will be
fine just do it like in the UML diagram
and it's it'll be glorious right this is
the whole authors got a bad name is
being very ivory tower I'm Richard to
the actual problem at hand and when
agile came along I just said we want to
get rid of doing things upfront we want
to you know the first iteration you
should be writing code and shipping code
out the door basically in a smallest
thing you can possibly release to
actually show some value from your
workday iteration so you don't want this
kind of planning phase
front right so where's architecture
gonna sit from our jaws point of view
because well we don't have this upfront
phase so what happened a little bit is
they began to say well maybe we need a
little bit of up front and that little
bit of up front is to do the things
we're incremental Ryoka touch is going
to fail because we've made a lot of
design decisions understand a particular
branch and set of paths which mean that
actually this particular approach over
here is out of reach now and if we
actually decided we needed that that's
almost too difficult to branch across to
find that we end up looking a hacky
solution as a result so the consequence
of that kind of shift from waterfall to
agile and this pushback against doing
design to being as little design as
possible put people in the position
where they began to regard the thing
that happens up front which they regard
as architecture as being things that are
too hard to change alright a problem
with this definition is that it makes
architecture a temporal property of the
system architecture exists at any point
in your life cycle you may have to make
significant design decisions the fact
that you might want to try and do those
before you start writing code is
irrelevant to the idea that you're going
to make architectural decisions about
difficult - my change design things
throughout the life of your system so
it's difficult to see architecture as
kind of this property that occurs in
some kind of temporal states right and
when you go and look at computer science
he discover it's been talking about
architecture and a lot since Carla 1990s
that you don't ever define architecture
as something that is hard to change
that's not the working definition they
use so the computer science guys when
they talk about what is software
architecture things that are hard to
change doesn't enter into them
cavalry tool alright so what is what is
so for architecture let's let's talk a
little bit about what architecture is
first because the other thing two
challenges Mullens perspective that
basically he said because his wife is a
modern architect that architecture as a
building manager the first person we
kind of know of that really defined and
as a Content that architecture was a
Roman engineer now being a Roman
engineer his job was essentially to
build fortifications and then to knock
them down heavy catapults but he was an
engineer nonetheless and he wrote a book
on architecture but it was called of
architecture basically and one of his
famous statements is a building certify
three pencils
Fermat asks you to a test in Venice
that's durability utility and beauty
actually I'm in a Latin speaking country
so you may not have needed me to
translate for you I don't know anyone
for me but yeah and I actually think
that you know if you're talking about
what architecture is supposed to do in
engineering terms right that's actually
not a bad definition even today for us
in software architecture that
architecture
what are gods of goes of architecture
when you're doing engineering is to
build something that exhibits these
three properties its durable its it has
utility and it has some kind of beauty
actually the last one is quite often
forgotten we talk about non-functional
requirements and for that we quite often
forget
beauty and I think maybe we should
perhaps put that back in the frame again
a bit more so here's the thought
experiment for example if you were to go
out to so you joined a new team like
I've done recently and he said somebody
can you described to me the architecture
of the system right
I can guarantee you people don't go to
you let me talk about the things that
are hard to change and the upfront
decisions we made about them because
that is the architecture of the system
what will do nine times out of ten is
they'll go to a whiteboard and they will
start drawing box and line diagrams okay
and that is what architecture tends to
be
what you might also get is a bit of a
history where they do say okay
pragmatically we made this choice and
here we decided to do this and at some
point you know we were never able to
solve this problem so we just hacked
around that and so you do get a
discussion about basically some of the
trade-offs that were made in order to
achieve the business's goals and those
two things or what instinctively people
will do when you ask them to say what is
the architecture of your system draw
some boxes and lines give you a potted
history of software development in the
organization that's our architecture and
that's I mean I every time I'd go
somewhere else that's pretty much the
same the same thing that you get and
actually Ralph Johnson which worked with
the guy who mind felt quoted in his
article who needs a Software Architect
is the guy who originally made this
statement that it's the hard things to
change actually had a lot more to say
but Martin like you know a good
journalist didn't report on all of those
in quite the same way he said this in
most systems the shared understanding of
the system by the kind of expert
software developers that's what the
architecture is right it's how it's how
you and I effectively say how does this
system work and basically one of the
important things for him was it's a
notion of how the system is partitioned
and how those parts that are partitioned
talk to each other one of the things to
understand a little bit from that
comment is that it isn't necessarily all
of the details when we talk about a
shared understanding of the system
we'll talk about some of those boxes and
line diagrams there's a certain amount
of abstraction going on in architecture
we say there's some detail here that
doesn't really matter to understand that
detail to understand how the system
works I said all the parts work together
how these moving bits and pieces create
motion you don't need to actually
understand the individual detail inside
the boxes there's a level of abstraction
we need that otherwise we just wouldn't
be able to cope no one better learn
about your architecture because unless
they'd been on the team right from the
beginning of the process and rent all
the code alongside you there is no way
they'd be able to effectively understand
it and so you've got to have that slight
lifting of level and so this is notion
graphed on two phrases as the components
that are understood by all the
developers but that notion should be
answered in terms of context imagine you
have like 4050 developers all working on
kind of separate teams and and
architectures really concerned with the
things that they have in common or they
all understand right
not this obscure little bit that these
two guys happen to know in the corner
that deals with some particular function
that they need to work with so when we
talk about computer science Mary Shaw
and David Garland wrote a book on
software architecture back in the 90s
they were at Carnegie Mellon University
in the US which are a lot of work on
software architecture and they
essentially said as a system grows it
becomes more important to understand the
structure of it than it does to
essentially understand individual
algorithms and data structures because
the problems you have will exist on that
kind of macro rather than that kind of
micro scale and that isn't to say that
an individual team is not going to have
to be concern itself with the algorithms
performance of a particular API it's got
etc but overall from the point of view
of making this whole reliable we start
to get into the world of Sam you've got
to deal with the larger building blocks
here and so software architecture could
be defined as basically the description
of these elements these large pieces and
the interactions that they have between
them and so and what they define in this
book is that software architecture is a
series of components and the
interactions between them and a lot of
the work that Merrill Debbie Garden did
was they created a thing called the
candidate problems in software
architecture so I think there are 13
problems and they range across different
fields from
I don't know something according to
website - automated navigation aids
floating out in the harbor and the idea
was to say well if you can effectively
define a architectural style as it's
cool
which is if you like I think of that as
a design pan but for architectures where
you say if I had this component and
these connectors and I applied these
constraints these rules about how these
components and collectors can talk to
each other or what their behaviour can
be then I can predict certain behaviors
about that architecture but I can also
then if I've described many marketers
that way compare them and figure out
what architectures apply better to some
of these candidate problems than others
and so they were trying to basically
promote the idea of architecture as a
field of scientific research where we
could come up with some mecca of
evaluating by some facts how this
architecture where it could be used what
its strengths and weaknesses were where
it shouldn't be used so the components
are this can I put is the box right when
you draw a box a box on the lines
diagram you are effectively doing
exactly the same thing that Mary Sean
David again proposed back in the
nineties and a component is your bought
a box and it's the unit of computation
right it's where stuff actually happens
and a line is a connector and just a
communication path between two units of
computation right that's that most of
you instinctively use and draw it I
don't know whether that just were that's
humanly instinctive or whether people
learnt this who the heck got it handed
down that's effectively where that those
whole boxes and line diagrams come from
such actual people mock boxes inline CC
book going oh you know you know and I'll
take you're not doing UML you should be
doing you're doing boxes and lines
diagrams that's what's rubbish right but
actually there's a boxes and lines
notation and it's giving in in their
book on software architecture and it
says a box is where things where things
are computed and the liner have the
things that compute to communicate and
you can apply constraints to them
there's dogs exercise vocab race of them
learn bass also can I konnichi melon
he come they came along later and wrote
software architecture and practiced a
few other people and he especially calls
out this idea that software architecture
has begun to be thought of as the heart
of the things that are hard to change
and says we disagree and they say it's
basically the things that effectively
you need to reason about the system and
its properties and this notion of
reasoning is quite important if we have
the wrong level of abstraction it
becomes quite hard to reason about the
system but at a high level level of
abstraction we start to talk about the
important pieces of the system then we
can begin to reason about how it might
work and what change might will happen
will have might impact stuff and that
may occur at different levels in
different organizations you know I've
gone from an organization that was kind
of like 80 people 80 engineers that has
peaked to one that's about 500 and so
your actual some of the areas where
you're dealing with architecture change
a little bit because you're starting to
look at even bigger picture and so you
actually have to have even more
abstraction and you still may not you
may not care at the level of what
individual teams necessarily doing
because you're trying to create
structures that are big enough you
should be able to reason about the
system as a whole and its properties and
how it behaves and how it works and so
the kind of idea here is that you can
say some of the structures in your
system are architectural II important
would be a while I'd say rather than a
structure is architectural and others
are essentially less architectural II
important that can be quite useful to
you by the way and one of the problems
I'll test quite often get when you're
working with teams is people don't like
the idea that they're being told what to
do and micromanaged and really you
probably don't want to micromanage them
and you don't need to because you don't
really care what happens at that level
of detail inside the box necessarily I
mean you might care but you don't have
to govern that what you have to govern
is the CIM is their components and the
connectors and how they will fit
together so that basically that team
although it's working in isolation can
work as part of the whole what you have
to have is an understanding of how their
work fits in also everybody else's work
to make the cohesive whole function
so here's some examples modular
structures basically the modular
structures effectively that the you know
when there are whole units of code or
data that basically we need to basically
build and those things go to make up our
system component research that this is
essentially a call back to Mary Shaw
earlier this is the boxes and lines
diagrams how do the parts once we built
them how do they connect together so the
top thing is how I build an individual
stack you know consists of in.net land a
number of assemblies or in Python and a
number of basically modules etc the
middle one is saying when having to talk
to each other and the bottom what
whoops-a-daisy the bottom one is
allocation structure so basically the
other one is quite commonly well that's
a logical model read some physical
models basically of how we're going to
run this actually a production system
okay so one of the things that I would
say is that the problem with this idea
of important decisions that was raised
by Martin and Grady is it's a narrative
how we came to live here is anyone read
anything by Simon Wardley from Ward Lee
Maps interesting guys she's gonna find
out on wooden Maps it's come under here
border things nice even talked about
waking up this idea for war dress which
I can either business planning tool he
said when he when he first became a CEO
he was an X develop Ernie what swept
through the ranks became CEO he assumed
there'd be this book or set of books
entitled you know how you do the CEO
thing and be set of rules you could
follow them and you would make fantastic
businesses happen and then he said he
discovered the words basically he said
as far as he could tell most of the
management for c-level positions was
basically a bunch of self-help books
sayings you know you know you will or a
powerful manager you are a strong man
and it's like absolutely nothing to
running a business and he was like well
hang on a minute how is that gonna work
and his analogy for this is he said once
upon a time if you wanted directions to
go somewhere someone would give you a
narrative and it would go something like
you know when he go down past the third
shot where mrs. big in splits she's
lovely you should pop in and see you
sometime and then you go up the hill
past the third okay
the left the one that's falling down
slightly with the bent tree that looks
like a duck and right that's how you got
somewhere and it works but it's kind of
ineffective and it doesn't allow you to
think about new ways of accomplishing
the goal of getting from A to B because
you have to keep following this same set
of narrative instructions so nowadays we
use a map we just could have a map the
map says here is a and B here's a
terrain in between and here's how you
navigate it and when you all you have as
an architectural record is here is the
important and hard-hearted here are the
things that are hard to change there are
decisions that we made is you have a
narrative like the former right you have
a description of how to get to get 18 B
but doesn't really tell you anything
about wanted to get to C or D with maybe
very nearby if you have a map if you
have essentially some notion of the
structure of the system and you can
navigate your way around it and you can
begin to reason about its properties and
you can to reason about what happens and
the new circumstances or when change
occurs and so one of the key things for
architecture for my perspective is to
ensure essentially that you have some
kind of map right some kind of idea of
how the system fits together and it's
like any map it's an abstraction and
admit some details okay most maps only
go down to a certain level of you know
need and they don't give you everything
right my Google Maps in here is
fantastic for navigating streets but
there's lots of things it misses out
like you know where are the entry points
to the sewers I don't need to know that
thanks very much it doesn't help me
achieve my goal which is to navigate
from A to B so Google Maps is a really
good level of detail for what I need it
to do which is get around but it doesn't
solve things that I don't need to
understand like how to repair the the
mains water right there are different
maps for that which the sewage and water
companies hold and they use those when
they want to solve their problems so you
need to basically make sure that you
don't
lose sights in the detail of enough a
bit broad enough picture to be able to
reason about software architectures so
this is sunsuit and basically that's the
age-old wisdom that you have to
understand the terrain that you are
fighting him if you do not understand
the terrain your enemies will overwhelm
you right and that's really what an
architect is trying to do I understand
the terrain which the battle is being
fought create a map so you can figure
out how to do that so here are some
classic maps there lots of different
approaches to defending software
architecture we'll just touch on a few
I'm not trying to teach them to you just
to just kind of cool them out so this is
called the four plus one view the four
plus one view has says we can represent
actually the software in different
different forms so this logical view is
war you and I might think of a UML
diagram of your classes it kind of says
hey how is the functionality provided by
the objects that basically the code that
the developers are writing the
development view is slightly higher
level than that it's the components that
essentially those classes form part of
that go to make up the software this
level is is interesting detail but this
global actually is better for helping
you reason about things and nowadays
quite often we don't tend to write so
many of those sort of class diagrams
we're not tryna do end to end generation
of code from diagrams but these are
still incredibly useful this idea what
is a component house it took the other
components here process views which are
effectively says well how does the whole
thing actually run you know I mean when
I turn this logical abstraction into
running processes on basically a disk
how's that gonna work and the physical
view which essentially is all about
things like networks and boxes that it's
deployed so that's where you're damaged
a diagram of your AWS kind of landscape
goes right it's one first time I'm
Brendan when I heard of Simon Brown so
this was so if you if you do have any
kind of it's got a book called from
developer to architecture so people that
developer roles that get kind of pushed
up to an architectural role it's quite
quite useful book he has a thing called
the c4 diagram so the c4 diagram is
context containers in components I don't
expect to read the diagram here it's
quite small where it's not for we're not
gonna run through an assignment examples
but the idea effectively is to say here
I define a context which really just
says I have a system it I live in my
organization it talks to things outside
my organization it is used by consumers
effectively etc and you have containers
so contain this next level down are
essentially bits of the system color
that are running hosting some kind of
infrastructure so container something
like from a dotnet point view I is app
server right application server that is
running some code they're effectively
talks to your users that talks to maybe
a database in the button in the back and
the background so it's the big pieces
that are actually running right so here
we have something on its web application
talks relational database it's got a no
sequel store if it's there can't accept
so what is the one of the large moving
parts of your application and down here
you have the component model so I break
one of those containers down and I
actually get components bits of my
system that effectively fit together to
do what I need so dr. Enders website you
can go and get my website and see quite
how it's done but this is actually quite
helpful to orient to you in terms of
drilling further down to the system to
get a sense of the structure and it's
good actually even at this level you can
begin to see you know and this is
roughly equivalent so kind of
microservice is the consistency are all
these built entirely differently do the
teams basically have entirely different
strategies for dealing with these
problems right how diverse is my
landscape in terms of the kit that I'm
running everywhere and at this level you
get a feel for what are the significant
concepts without having to understand
the detail of the actual classes that
break them up right so this is my order
processing it may have some kind of
shopping basket and whatever effectively
questions so I did so I can track down
that and that also helps understanding
ownership or which team tends to own
this particular area of the system and
behavior or Nike
go and talk to them and figure out what
their problems are or whether they done
things right or wrong
okay this is essentially boxes and lines
diagram from architectural styles so you
do a component collector diagram if you
want to be a little bit more strict and
if you're doing whiteboards so this is
essentially a box representing a locus
of state your line is your connector
between two items this is essentially
port that's where effectively you
connect into a component and your it's
usually defined as a role and the idea
is that you basically tooken start with
one box right and you could say that's
my system and then there decomposable so
if that box itself will consist of the
other set of boxes and lines and you go
all the way down with boxes and lines so
really that's just a more sophisticated
version of that right so I was actually
giving you a slightly stronger guidance
on how to basically do that kind of
decomposition from potentially that this
goes this box becomes a number of these
boxes which become a number of these
boxes right so imagine that you join a
team and you've been down through the
exercise you said okay draw me the
architecture and you've got some boxes
and lines diagram up or maybe you've got
a c4 diagram or a 4+1 diagram or some
fancy UML and and you're saying okay the
next question I need to understand is is
the architecture you've drawn any good
remember we've talked earlier about the
idea that architecture was about saying
hey this is I'm building something and I
want to build something that has these
qualities of durability utility and
beauty how am I gonna figure that out um
most likely you'd probably want to look
for a number of things suitability for
purpose right
how well does this architecture meet the
business problem that they've been
presented with had they just decided
that they read an article basically on a
blog post last
and they really really want to do this
particular architectural style they saw
there because it's going to look great
on their CV
even if actually it bears no relation to
the problem that they have at hand right
we really must it's the whole kind of
like you know checkbox exercise in
design
I really must use Kafka it's gonna look
great on my CV I must find some part of
this system where I could use Kafka in
order to base to make that happen right
the super purpose essential not
accidental complexity but having me
understand is the fiction essential
complexity is the things that I need to
do to the job and accidental complexity
says the tools that I bring with me to
do that job may carry with them some
complexity that I'm not using so it's
quite commonly seen in say software
programming languages right if I only
use 60% of the language and there's
another 40% I don't use that's
essentially accidental complexity it's
things that are a burden for me now
because people might try and use them
use them incorrectly or people like this
basically say what is this and I have a
learning challenge right so that's
accidental complexity things that I'm
not using which might make the problem
worse so for example one of the things
it's a good example is B C++ right if
what I'm doing is just writing a line of
business application the memory
management overhead and C++ the step
that I have to do it myself it's
probably accidental complexity for me it
doesn't solve any problems that I need
to get solved it's essentially just
adding a burden to me to move forward
whereas if I'm writing a games games
engine that kind of memory management is
essential complexity for me I need to
better take control that memory and
manage it correctly so using the wrong
tool for the job can give you basic too
much accent of complexity and easy
modification to change in requirements
so it's the age-old problem that
effectively you know version your
software actually spends most of it's
life changing and we have to write
software that is suitable for change
I once work with the team that built a
piece of software and they they seem to
be following all the right steps right
they worked really closely with the
customer he was almost like customer on
site
he helped define it version 1 was a
triumph
everyone was celebrating how
in this piece of software Wars and then
we discovered a bunch of contractors we
service cover 6monthsoff they've kind of
gone that changing it was a nightmare
and that the way they done it
essentially where a whole load of
effectively very tailored stored
procedures built for every single page
that meant that that there had no sort
of common codes in common operations
such a and the whole thing was really
difficult to change and that meant we
just through the software away because
the cost of the lifetime cost of it was
full of likely to be too great to
actually keep maintaining it and I think
it's like the use of number given is
like 90% by their work where that
actually comes from as a figure of your
software's lifespan is for it's spent in
making effectively post version one and
if you can't change it it becomes a very
expensive proposition to own and nearly
everywhere I've been in the last few
years one of the key problems has been
quite often the first thing I arrived is
their problem is that they are stuck and
they can't move forward because they
can't change the software typically you
see the scenario where they've got no
unit tests because they've got unit
tests they find it's has to find it very
hard to refactor because they can't
refactor quite often they've just forked
bits of the software over time because
they don't want to change it so this
thing is exactly like this thing has a
slight variation but I was too
frightened to change the thing that
already exists in case it broke because
I don't have any tests to tell me
so just fortune created a new version
right impenetrable data structures that
are unperformed at the scale though
suddenly there's that they succeeded as
a business and they're starting to scale
up but the data structures don't work
most people can't change them because
everything is coupled into that one data
structure and those kind of problems I
can what a fly ability or what you know
we were to tend to say basically is a
bad architecture all right and so what
we might want to say is well we we
should go and look at the quality
attributes of the system I define what
quality attributes are in a second for
those of you don't know the alert is
that sometimes called right what we look
at and also seek basically high cohesion
and low coupling and so if the software
architecture has basically appropriate
quality attribute
it's I say appropriate because they do
very and high cohesion and low coupling
we probably have a good architecture so
this notion of quadrature is the main
place I have seen defined as it is again
basically while M baths and software
architecture and practice and he says
there's this distinction between the
functional requirements and the quality
attributes right and the functional
requirements are washer the software do
and the quality attributes are when it
does it what are the trade-offs we are
making in terms of our design decisions
so this idea is that you know there are
many ways to skin a cat there are many
ways quite often to build a software
solution solve a given problem and the
question is which one is better and the
answer is that isn't really as simple as
that it's why people give you the whole
it depends answer so really you have a
set of sliders so what a traditional
this would be modify ability how hard is
it to change
usability how how easy is it to use
security testability availability
performance interoperability and the
trick of course is is that you one slide
one along I want loss and waterfall
ability you quite often slide others
down the opposite direction right so you
perceive each item modify liability all
over and you performed this may drop off
right I've started he's an ORM because
it means my guys can just basically
write plain old C sharp objects and
generate the code out for basically the
whole persistence layer and I'm getting
to market really fast now it's brilliant
right but then when I come to scale all
that lazy loading is now killing me etc
right so now I have to dark
suddenly I need to be better performance
better availability I slide those
sliders back with my modify ability
drops off the code becomes harder to use
now so for example one of my primary
roles we had to do a whole thing where
we said well we will have no one to many
relationships anyway right you can your
your children can see the parent and so
effectively if when we want to do a read
from a read store that's fine they know
who their parent is but in the right
store we never ever see scenarios where
you genuinely have to load all the
children you're usually working with one
child you said to know who your parent
is so well so that will have a rule that
you shouldn't ever try and code
into the system so people aren't tempted
to write code that says load this
objects in all its children right and
that kind of problem happens to you
because your dials have shifted that
suddenly you need to basically pull this
this dial back over here which is just
the other one and those quality actually
sir try to set trade-offs and the only
way you can figure out whether
trade-offs are is to understand the
business and are isn't you to support
how many users how quick it has to be et
cetera can the customer wait for a reply
on this does the customer have to sit
there effectively and receive the
response in front of them etc alright
and so there is no answer that says this
architecture is always better than this
architecture there is simply this
architecture has tends to support these
quality attributes and if you can map
those quality attributes onto a business
problem that's probably a good
architectural fit for that particular
problem you want to solve and they're
also constraints right and perspective
things like well we're a Microsoft shop
when we're on Windows servers right and
you're giving your you just don't get to
change usually and you have to work
within it when in terms of its
architecture so what you can do so this
book by the way is a guy called Michael
clean design anyone read design it a
good book if you if you have a kind of
architectural responsibility and don't
release it the other book in the
pragmatic programmer series Michael my
god tree both of those parent
programmers have two really good books
of people that have kind of architecture
net title one is release it and the
other one is design it they're both the
worst name books that I've ever come
across in my entire life release it as
far as I can tell has nothing to do with
releasing software it's all basically to
do what we would now go now call
reliability engineering and design it
has nothing to do with being a UX
designer it has everything to do with
being a software architect and leading
teams doing architecture I have no idea
where the naming is so bad I presume
that they may come up with a third or
fourth book in that series and it will
be equally unclear from the names what
the book etch is about but he's just a
thing
called a virtually quality attribute web
so essentially I mean you can use
circles right become with a series of
concentric rings and kind of the the
points he essentially says right you can
put the different quality attributes and
then the post-it notes represents
scenarios that you need to support and
those scenarios essentially turn the
dials on some of these predictive and
quality attributes closer towards the
center is stronger and closer towards
the outside is weaker so the idea is
essentially that you can see all the
things that lead you to given particular
trade-offs here you can see that
availability is very important to this
system right more so than modify ability
or performance and security is quite
important so as you begin to map out
those scenarios you can see which of
those quality attributes you're tending
to push in favor of over others because
a kind of reality is you're not going to
be able to satisfy all of them then as
you slide one way the start has pushed
the other way for you at the same time
and so one of the idea is basically in
designer is this idea that you partition
the system in order to meet quality
attributes all right one of the reasons
you break things up is because that
helps you effectively gives you more
flexibility and how you can omit those
quality atrophied requirements okay so
we talked briefly love about
partitioning hadley partition a system
and that's a whole talk in itself right
I think did Adam do he's talked about
partitioning I think breaking up
microservice thinking right done this
Porter this is the classic domain driven
design basically where effectively you
do context mapping as an exercise where
you figure out all the bounded context
your system so bounded context if you
like is a portion of the domain where
you have people who speak a common
language in the business and use the set
of terminology and generally have a kind
of shared perspective of the business
and you can map your system as a whole
set of these I worked for a while
surance and insurance is very
interesting Squier really nice one to
return train your wheels on because
there's a notion of policy in insurance
and lots of pallets of the business have
a Polish national policy claims team
deal with a policy the underwriting team
deal with the policy the actuarial team
deal with a policy but what they
actually record about policies that are
entirely different in each context so
the claims guys are really focused on
what is it you're actually covered for
the underwriting team focused on what is
it you're actually insuring right the
actuarial team are kind of somewhere a
little bit in between like how do we
make money from basically that this
particular sole problem of offering
insurance and I can remember at some
pump when I work this insurance company
boss came to see me very excited and
he'd been in a golf course because if
you're an architect all the boss best
stories start with your boss being on a
golf course and he said someone came to
me and they said for $40,000 I can give
you a model of insurance you're Mel
diagrams that will mean your team will
be saved countless hours of work because
they will simply be able to implement
this UML diagram for forty thousand it
can be yours my boss was very excited he
said this forty thousand pound seems
like a lot but in terms of development
time we we quickly burned through that
this must be the way to reduce our you
get get our products out the door faster
in and I said what can I have a look at
this thing before we buy it and he said
yes yes I think they said you can have a
you know sort of peek at it so have a
look so their policy they only had what
they have done any of this partitioning
they just had one thing called a policy
right and it did life insurance and it
did investment vehicles basically and it
had the same kind of thing over here but
nothing called a icer which is basically
a you go and purchase some shares and
stick them in a bucket and the
government doesn't tax you very much
right and it can do your car and it
could do your massive commercial
building and it's kind of like well how
many feels does this thing have or it's
appears to have something like 800 or
fields in it in this one class called
policy right
and every single part of the business it
had the things they needed oh it's a
claim where it's got this whole section
of effectively coverage clauses inside
it oh it's got this actual
rating plan built-ins and it's like this
thing was enormous and the problem was
because they just heard the word policy
they went literally round the kind of
room and said well what do you know
about policies little list of it all out
and bolted it onto a policy or is what
you actually want to do is listen to
each individual part of the business
that has their own view of the domain
and say I gotta create a policy for you
and a policy for you that is what you
care about even though even though then
what the word is the same they view it
entirely differently and you and I had a
number of meetings in shorts where you
could see this quite clearly where you'd
literally get cheaper than I could
underwriter on a claims guy and they
would be arguing they'd be arguing
because the other guy didn't know what
he was talking about when he used the
word policy that's quite clear coming
example so breaking that's where
partitioning the system I want let me
talk about boasting meeting quality
attributes well people do that kind of
thing and then these things like say
okay well we're going to make each one
of those in an independently deployable
unit and we'll call it micro services
right so that's how partitioning can
then help you basing me some quality
attributes and they've upon us very
classic paper lot you press it white
papers you can you can go and read on
the criteria to be used on basically on
the decomposition of software into
modules he effect he was one that people
early on which said you know what
partitioning the system is about hiding
the difficult implementation details
behind something that's abstract and
stable so but after often thought at
that point a lot of kind of partitioning
and occur by flow here are the steps in
the system I'll divide up in the big
chunks each one of those chunks as a
partition that's why module and he said
that isn't really gonna work what you're
much better off doing is saying what are
the difficult decisions that I have to
make can i put things that basically
alright to that decision into a bucket
and can I put a stable interface over
the top so everybody else can depend on
that stable abstraction because my it
won't change very much but you can
change the data so sex for example I was
shipping things between a and B and I
wanted to have some way of character in
the best route I can put an abstraction
which basically says calculate route and
everyone else can depend on my calculate
route abstraction because it just says
well put in the
the origin and the destination and I
will tell you the best way to get there
but if I come up with new and better
algorithms for solving the problem of
how do I get from A to B for the
cheapest possible path I can change all
those internals quite happily and nobody
else cares right and that again it's
partitioning because it makes it
possible for the team that own is that
problem to innovate without impacting
any of the other teams okay right so
when I said we're into what is agile for
a second so we will come back to some of
the conversation in a little bit trying
to put it into your stack and try and
remember we're talking about the
beginning as well and we'll try and
start tying all together in a second and
magic will hopefully occur from the
various threads that I have spun out I
get to the audience so this is basically
what a waterfall project looks like
could anyone here worked on a waterfall
project
okay cool
usually the problem nowadays is that
there are a few of us left and so when
you describe agile people don't know
what it was agile by comparison to which
is waterfall but the the essential
problem is effectively okay it was
designed in a period where effectively
computation was expensive and so it was
easier to make decisions on bits of
paper and and theorize about how your
software is going to work and then
implement it then it was to effectively
have some process of iteration which let
you do that instead nowadays basically
building and shipping software is very
very cheap and so we could actually move
to a different model Alastair Coburn
describes this is basically what he says
is a late learning strategy right so
effectively I build and I build and I
build in my building but I don't ship I
learn nothing about decisions I've made
right until the end of the process so
effectively I carry a lot of risk so
iterative development so rapid
especially rapid development and rapid
development is really where most edge
approaches come from kind of said all
right you know what we're gonna do we're
gonna deliver in iteratively and
incrementally we're gonna deliver small
chunks of functionality
I'm gonna deliver them on a regular
basis right so it's important to be by
the iterative and incremental you can't
be iterative and not be incremental and
still be rapid application development
you can do a whole lot of sprints
you don't see from the right until the
end it hasn't helped you okay and so
that was this notion basically a rapid
application development and that well as
a Grove of code would describe that's a
risk reduction strategy right so I get
knowledge very early on in the process
about what I'm building
and I'm therefore able to reduce the
risk because if it turns I've gotten on
the wrong path I can change my course
and I can adjust all right now quick tip
you should ignore the agile software
manifesto the agile software manifesto
is essentially a bit like Donald Trump
and his summit in North Korea nothing
was actually achieved and but they come
out at the end to make a lovely
statement right so when they made this
statement even about two hours before
Martin Fowler would not agree to call it
agile and this is this literally this
statement is all they could manage to
agree or now for a number of days of
working but they all had different
methodologies that fell into this kind
of camp that they weren't basically
waterfall that rapid application
development ologies right so that's that
most people hold this is the tablet of
stone if that's what agile is and it's
not what is agile agile is basically
risk reduction strategy and the idea
basically it says I want to effectively
perform a series of experiments and get
feedback from those experiments it's a
way of shortening your feedback loop as
much as far as fast as you can to get
your data back right and it started with
a lightweight although ceremony
so how do we do agile in architecture
and agile so this is James Shore Jim
Schwartz got a really good book called
the art of agile and is a fantastic book
if you want to do experience thing like
that it's really good but one of James's
things he's saying there is you know
actually you don't have any kind of
thing up front you just go straight into
the code and you start working and the
problem of that is you will have an
architecture
if architecture essentially is the
structure your system system will have a
structure if you don't design one you'll
get one that's properties called
emergent architecture right
we're actually architecture know you're
gonna get one but you don't you look it
to avoid having an architecture you have
one you didn't think about it so there
are actually in a lot of agile
methodologies a part of the process we
begin to have some architectural
thinking at the beginning the process
okay and the idea is that essentially in
order to build software that is
evolutionary in other words that we can
do iterative and collective development
with we quite often have to do just
enough upfront to actually put in place
to context that helps that and that the
problem is that some of the early
practitioners of XP excetera were very
experienced software developers for whom
some of the things that you needed to do
were just very natural they didn't
automatically and what people asked the
pointed out is when you get less
experienced teams they're not
automatically doing those things and
actually from their point of view it
helps them to step back for a little bit
and have a bit of thought before they
actually tackle the work just because
essentially you're you are optimizing it
you're saying because of my lack of
experience I'm going to basically
compensate for that by giving you a
little bit about front thinking time
before you actually get started writing
code and you can see this in lots of
situations when you interact with people
right some people the way they work
actually they might refer to a bit of
reading time a bit time to think before
they go and discuss the problem with you
okay and so they you can benefit from a
little bit of thought right so let's get
back to this statement the great
Buddhist making originally he's saying
basically hey architecture is the
basically significant decisions that
you're making so don't add your project
one way to think
this is actually this is not the
architecture with structure the system
this is the practice of architecture
this is what architects do the
architects say well when I look at the
structure of the system I'm gonna be
building all I need to have a think
about the bits that are gonna be hard to
change or significant in terms of cost
right that's what I need to focus on and
so say for example Cristal has this
process where effectively it says okay
during the kind of initial part of the
project we can run this thing the
retention coordinates poetry 360 well we
are should we could we how would we and
the time that the timescales elastic
it's probably no more than two weeks it
might be as short as a day depending on
the size what you're building but you
kind of sample these that the problem
space you say kind of how would we build
this a lot very technologies we open you
think they might want to use do we want
to experiment with so what we call
spikes so you can figure out whether
they be suitable for us to actually use
here or not right rather than say I'm
gonna use it in the first cup of
iterations then throw it away if it
doesn't work actually say well just give
it a little try will probe and see
what's there
and they'll give us a feel for where
they're actually it's are workable to me
are to me our solutions although they're
only discussions we need to have with a
business about the things that they want
the system to do where we can see that
this option is incredibly expensive this
option of actually they didn't mention
is a lot cheaper and maybe if they knew
that other option exists that they
depict that one right so there's an you
have to do a little bit of upfront
thinking and effectively what you're
trying to do is establish the technical
flaws but it's a project right so XP has
something else they call the exploratory
phase but the same thing effectively
they are trying to understand all the
technologies they will use to create a
production system and they do it before
the iteration process starts so actually
there is I would say to you a distinct
architectural place in most agile
processes there's a little economist
that notion were just enough upfront
design so this is notion we are used to
quite a lot called a walking skeleton
the idea effectively is that you can't
look at what come at the plan you say
here are the key things that are all
essentially significant for us to solve
its problems and you build Justin
software to exercise that problem space
and prove to yourself that you actually
do have a workable solution before you
put the flesh on it so you D risk
effectively your architectural
challenges as soon as you can so that
you're fencing if you discover the
structure of your system is completely
wrong it's much easier than to throw it
away and build another one before you
started building all the features on top
which then becomes very expensive to
effectively go in and actually change
that in that structure once you have it
and you own it okay let's go fast
through that slide so what you're trying
to do essentially is get to this idea of
saying I want to basically as fast as
possible increase my knowledge of the
choices that I'm making from about the
structure of the system and when I
validated those I'll be able to move on
with the functional work and if agile is
a idea of doing experiments and getting
feedback we should do experiments and
get feedback about the proposed
structure of the system and whether it
meets the quality attributes that we
expect from it okay just saying that
again right so as an architect you have
a lot of tools and the question
basically effectively is if I talk about
DDD context book mapping all those
diagrams etc I thought about basically
walking skirts and spikes all those
things to try and do this work can we
give you any advice on when you should
use any of those over others and we
talked about there getting this notion
of things that are hard to change such
but we can actually generalize that and
say our project probably has some
identifiable risks we can't figure out
where they are we can all probably sit
in a room and have kind of a what am I
afraid of session right and we can say
those are the risks those are the things
that we think may burn us as we go and
build out this system and those are the
places in this kind of Ehrlich's proxy
phase will we spend our time right this
is a diagram from a really good white
paper you can go and record how much
upfront and it's essentially it says
what are the trade-offs and the way you
do things so here are essentially for
example saying my decision is to have
that how much I go full-on basically
agile or do some design up front
depends on forces such as what's the
experience the developers on working
with how agile is the customer what is
the culture that they have already right
if I have a very inexperienced team with
a custom that's not very agile and the
culture is not very unlike agile it may
be that this process effectively is
moving into a kind of response to change
iterative architectures not going to
work for me okay I'm over time slightly
off all right cool so we'll just speed
to this tiny bit looks I'm running over
time but I think ok so who is the
Software Architect
generally speaking it's a role and it
may not necessarily be a useful title
the reasonably useful title is because
if you give someone the word architect
in that title implies that they are
responsible for the architecture of the
system and actually everyone responsive
for the architecture of the system this
is one of the things that Martin
essentially objects to which is the
matrix figure forgetting the matrix the
old Whitehead guy sitting in the room
right who is Lord of the whole domain
and the problem of that is everybody
needs to be involved in architecture so
architecture is kind of a role and which
some people may effectively have a role
of being an architect and since they
have some responsibility for shaping the
structure of the system
Simon basic comes up with this list of
things that you will do as a Software
Architect most of those are probably
hopefully reasonably understandable but
I my model tells me that you do these
three things you build them you help the
teams build software right you don't
build it yourself use you but you help
the teams build it and deliver it you
mentor them particularly mentor them in
architectural concerns you get you help
the team see the wider picture in the
context that they're engaged with I need
you stakeholder management and that's
the bit that everyone hates and that
says basically you have to talk to the
business you have to talk to all the
stakeholders have to explain what the
team is doing has to run into first the
team and say the team wants to build
this complex technical thing and this is
what we're going to have to do it right
so that's the politics bit you have to
basically make sure that expectation is
satisfied ok I'm going to detail these
slides but at the time but this is Dada
it's by Scott Ambler I don't say like
dad I'm not promoting it as a particular
agile methodology but it has some useful
team structure diagrams wanting to go
and look at and one of the things it's
really trying to say is there are some
primary roles that roles rather than job
hunters and some secondary roles and
architecture owners a primary role in
that what they kind of say is depending
on the size of the team you may or may
not have an explicit architect so here
they're saying in a small team you know
scrum XP style team of does lots of
people your team lead well maybe the
architecture owner right if that the
size of your practice the size of your
overall project is about 12 people then
maybe the team leads also the architect
he has that role he got towards 10 to 40
people though you may need to change
that so you may at that point have to
say well actually we're gonna have to
basically have someone who's an explicit
architecture owner who sits over
effectively a number of these teams
right so he may own two or three teams
and help them look after their
architecture so some places call this
kind of role more a principal engineer
kind of role right some of these
basically helping a number of teams
succeed at their goal and if you get a
really large organization right then you
may end up with architecture as an
actual leadership team where the people
who are architecture owners to these
smaller groups gather together in some
kind of committee and discuss the
overall direction of the overall
platform that you're building and it in
its given direction but my warning is
this right somebody always ends up in
that role and if you don't decide who it
is much as the same way that you will
always have an architecture whether you
want one or not you will always get an
architect and the thing is it may be the
guy who's the biggest bully in the team
if you don't pick the guy who's actually
got the most capability to do the job
and so where I see teams say we don't
need an architect we don't need an
architectural owner I always think
that's very dangerous that tends to mean
the quiet guy who may actually be very
smart he's gonna get eliminated from the
process you need to actually have
somebody who you can go to and say hey
what is the structure what you're doing
what does it look like what are the did
what are the trade-offs are being forced
to make
right what are the risks you need to
manage to succeed and so I would always
try and make sure you explicitly choose
somebody and delegate that person having
technical authority in the team all
right so I'm about to wrap I think yeah
so this is just basically saying if you
have if you have architecting job title
tool please remember if actually one of
your main jobs is to help everybody else
do architecture right it's not to
basically say I'm gonna go through my
secret bunker and come back with the
plans here you meet with everybody else
in a room when you might put it out
together and you figure out what you're
gonna do right
you ought you are facilitator of
architecture happening and this is
basically what's called an architectural
design studio which is this idea
effectively you hold a meeting you bit
of what yet when involved you do some
brainstorming you everyone puts their
ideas up without critique and then
effectively the last stage is to
essentially reject or approve those
ideas of the team right
and so this stage is important because
sometimes somebody comes up the really
left field concept and it turns out that
actually is brilliant and you wouldn't
have got that out if everyone has been
afraid of the criticism happening too
early on all right so there you go
hopefully to kind of wrap up you can see
that my point would point is there's a
myth out there that we don't need
software architects because in a a July
or ghen izing teams that kind of
position is no longer required but I
think it's based on a couple of false
notions this notion of the architect
sitting in his remote room dispensing
tablets of stone at the beginning of a
waterfall or into process and that when
we consider that the architecture is the
structure of the system it will always
have one and that we can identify what
good structures are there ones were the
quality attributes of the system and
it's partitioning and low coupling I
mean that effectively we have something
that is if you like durable has utility
and has beauty then effectively there is
definitely a need for an architect to
help build that and in an agile space
there
is a clear portion of the agile
lifecycle where we do some upfront
architecture but continue to actually do
architecture throughout the lifecycle as
a kind of guidance around that
structural representation and that there
will always be somebody effectively who
fills that vacuum if you don't declare
it and that's that's that thank you very
much
[Applause]